I recommend a few books per year some of
those are targeted at a certain group of
viewers because some books are mainly
relevant for a specific audience
but occasionally there's a book that
everyone needs at least everyone who
watches my channel and here's one of
those books the critical Quran by Robert
Spencer
how do I know that Robert Spencer's
critical Quran is a masterpiece two ways
first it's by Robert Spencer Robert only
puts out extremely high quality content
especially when it's a project like this
second true story I put together a
little test before I started reading I
decided that I would read the first
chapter
but that before reading I would make a
mental list of the points that
definitely needed to be included in the
commentary
Robert's main focus for the past two
decades has been on Jihad but there are
a lot of important problems in the Quran
that have nothing to do with Jihad so I
wanted to know if Robert was going to
cover them
those of you who've had a lot of
discussions or arguments with our Muslim
friends over the years may know what the
main problems with Surat Al Fatiha are I
made a mental list of four things that
were most important before I went to the
chapter in the critical Quran here's
what I came up with before going to the
text
one Muhammad's companion IBN Masood
didn't believe that Surat Al Fatiha is
supposed to be in the Quran the Quran is
supposed to be Allah speaking to man not
man speaking to Allah but Surah
al-fatiha is a prayer to Allah so IBN
Masood concluded that this chapter
shouldn't be in the Quran this is a
massive problem because Muhammad told
his followers if you want to learn the
Quran learn it from IBN Masood and IBN
Masood had a different Quran from the
one Muslims have today
to Surat al-fatiha is a prayer but
normally in the Quran when Allah is
telling human beings to say something he
begins with the word say he says say
this
but Surah Al Fatiha doesn't begin with
say this which means that since the
Quran is Allah's Eternal speech Allah
has been reciting a prayer for all
eternity
why is this relevant well Surat Al
Fatiha says praise be to Allah and guide
us to the straight path
so for all eternity Allah has been
praising himself and asking himself to
guide himself to the straight path
very confusing
three there's a textual variant in verse
four most Muslims are still convinced
that there are no textual variants in
the Quran so there's a refutation of
their belief in verse 4.
finally verse 7 asks Allah not to guide
the people who are praying to the path
of those who have earned his anger or of
those who have gone astray
but those two phrases those who have
earned your anger and those who have
gone astray refer specifically to Jews
and Christians this is important because
churches have had Interfaith Services
where Muslims have the Christians recite
this prayer and if you don't understand
what the prayer means it's actually a
prayer not to be a Jew or a Christian
so those are the four issues I thought
needed to be included in the commentary
on Surat Al Fatiha what did I find when
I opened the critical Quran and started
reading
here's the introduction to Surat Al
Fatiha right here towards the end we
find yet in an indication of the
fluidity of the quranic text in the
early days of Islam Abdullah IBN Masood
one of Muhammad's companions did not
even have this Surah in his version of
the Quran other early Islamic
authorities also expressed reservations
about its inclusion so Robert points out
the IBN Masood problem but also notes
that other early Muslims had a problem
with the first chapter of the Quran
next paragraph to be sure this Surah
does not fit in with the rest of the
Quran in that it is in the voice of the
believer offering prayer and praise to
Allah not Allah addressing Muhammad
Islamic Orthodoxy has it that Allah is
the speaker in every part of the Quran
so with al-fatiha the believer must
accept that the deity is explaining how
he should be prayed to without
explaining directly that that is what he
is doing
so Muslims have to assume that Allah
wants them to say this even though it's
Allah speaking meaning that Allah has
been reciting a prayer from all eternity
looks like Robert's two for two so far
then we have the Surah in the name of
Allah the compassionate the merciful
praise be to Allah the lord of the
worlds the compassionate the merciful
Master of the day of judgment you do we
worship you do we ask for help guide us
to the straight path the path of Those
whom you have favored not of those who
have earned your anger or of those who
have gone astray
we go to the comments and we find more
about the problem of Allah reciting this
prayer in Islamic theology Allah is the
speaker of every word of the Quran some
have found it strange that Allah would
say something like praise be to Allah
the lord of the worlds but Islamic
tradition holds that Allah revealed this
prayer to Muhammad early in his career
as a prophet which began in the year 610
A.D when he received his first
revelation from Allah through the angel
Gabriel a revelation that is now
contained in the quran's 96th Surah so
that the Muslims would know how to pray
so we've got the problem and the
standard Muslim response to the problem
then we have a note on verse 4. instead
of Master of the day of judgment the
warsh Quran has King of the day of
judgment that's the textual variant I
was looking for but there are notes on
other textual variants that I didn't
know about and then we have a lengthy
note on verse 7 that begins Islamic
scholars have often identified those who
have earned Allah's anger as the Jews
and those who have gone astray as the
Christians and it goes through the
Muslim sources and commentaries and
proves that this verse is actually
condemning Jews and Christians
so this Quran has everything I would be
looking for and more
and if it's got everything I would be
looking for and more it's probably got
everything you would be looking for and
more so order a copy of the critical
Quran and either read the entire thing
or use it to study some particular
topics you're interested in or keep it
handy for discussions when someone
brings up a verse and you want to make
sure someone's not trying to deceive you
the link is in the description box
order a copy and join Robert Spencer and
David wood in exposing 14 centuries of
deception
[Music]